[Music]
so April 27 2017 was the greatest day in
the history of twitter.com net.gov I
realize that to you children Twitter is
an app but to us mils it remains a
website we have to dial in
[Music]
Hello Operator connect me to hell this
was the day that fire Festival a luxury
music event hosted by jaw Rule and some
charlatan was scheduled to begin on a
private island in the Bahamas there was
a lot of hype Kendall Jenner and Bella
Hadid endorsed the festival on Instagram
there was a promo video full of
supermodels tickets were selling for
thousands of dollars one Twitter thread
summarized the marketing as exclusivity
conspicuous consumption and and many
many promises of excellent selfies for
your already insufferable Instagram so
when the day arrived and the advertised
best in food art music and Adventure
turned out to be two slices of pallet
American cheese languishing over sliced
bread in an atmosphere that can only be
described as muddy third world shanty
town I mean if you weren't on Twitter
that day I don't think you can even
imagine the rry just learned about fire
Festival AKA jaw rues concentration camp
for Instagram models and rich white kids
yepy Hunger Games hosted by jaw Ru
finish your food there's starving
Millennial influencers in fire Festival
Instagram entitled Rich Kids meet Lord
of the Flies let them eat salad it was a
shuttering climax of pent up class rage
you know maybe Millennials couldn't get
Bernie Sanders elected but at least
those sandwiches were garbage
Jamila J is an English actress who's
just extremely pretty imagine looking
like this imagine being perfect why are
you doing this to me jamaa why are you
doing this to women one day on Instagram
an ordinary peasant told the queen Jam
your skin is so perfect ooo and jamaa
replied my skin is currently clear
because a privileged people have more
access to good quality nutrition and
also our lives are significantly less
stressful than those with less privilege
I also get to sleep more because of this
all of these things keep my hormones in
balance and I'm able to address food
intolerances easily B I believe that
trans rights are human rights see I
exfoliate twice a week oh boy Jam
they're going to cut your head off Gorge
I'll protect you Queen could she be any
more annoying someone wandered on
Twitter to 77,000 likes this trend of
fake self-awareness legit makes me want
to rip my hair out now look to be fair
everything Jam said is true being
privileged does make it easier to spend
time and money on Cosmetics but jamila's
acknowledging this this recitation of
all the complex socioeconomic factors
that account for why she's prettier than
you doesn't take any of the sting out of
inequality does it and that's kind of at
odds with what activists used to say
which is that you should check your
privilege a suggestion which the
privileged seemed to have taken to Heart
since the rich and famous now go around
delivering these orations on how
fortunate they are compared to the Rabel
and this of course turns out to be far
more annoying than when they acted
oblivious to it I don't have any beauty
secrets I guess I just drink lots of
water take me mother a similar Scandal
occurred when Kim Kardashian tweeted
about her birthday party at the height
of the Corona virus pandemic 40 and
feeling so humbled and blessed there is
not a single day that I take for granted
especially during these times when we
are all reminded of the things that
truly matter after 2 weeks of multiple
Health screens and asking everyone to
quarantine I surprised my closest inner
circle with a trip to a private island
where we could pretend things were
normal for just a brief moment in time I
realized that for most people this is
something that is so far Out Of Reach
right now so in moments like these I'm
humbly reminded of how privileged my
life is # this is40 tag me [ __ ] so like
jam Kim is attempting some kind of
privilege checking maneuver and once
again it has not gone well you are the
Marie Anette of the 21st century
bragging about being humble and letting
us eat cake millions of Americans sick
and suffering standing for hours in food
lines and being evicted as you flaunt
your wealth and privilege your Tweet
made 10 times worse by # tonev humbled
and blessed line # gross happy
birthday I hope somebody got you an
alphabet book as a gift so you can read
the [ __ ] so the response on
Twitter resembles moral outrage but what
people were upset about was not that she
had the party I mean wouldn't you escape
to a private island if you got that mil
money the problem was more that she
tweeted about it and that the Tweet was
maybe just maybe a little bit yikes but
if having the party wasn't wrong then
why was tweeting about it wrong this
isn't a good look we say bad Optics not
relatable relatable relatability is not
a moral category this is public
relations it's not ethics and it
definitely isn't socialism like I'm
pretty sure Carl Marx never said the
problem with the Bazi is they are not
relatable they can't read the room and
it isn't good look this should have
stayed in the drafts # tonee isn't the
issue that when Kim tweeted this most
people were trapped in quarantine we
didn't get to have birthday parties some
people couldn't even travel to visit
their dying relatives so watching Kim
get to travel and celebrate her birthday
like normal was painful pain at the Good
Fortune of others is how Aristotle
defined envy and I think it's
interesting that whenever social media
erupts an outrage over luxury music
festivals or Kim K's birthday party or
Jam
J's privileged pores no one ever uses
the word envy it's like we're averting
our eyes avoiding confrontation with
this dark aspect of our own psychology
so in this video I want to take a long
hard look at Envy what is it where does
it come from and seriously what is Jam
Jam's skincare routine drop it in the
comments bestie okay so what is Envy
pain at the Good Fortune of others is
not a bad start but there's more to it
than that Envy is a syndrome a complex
of poisonous thoughts and feelings about
people who have what we want but cannot
get it's not simply wanting what another
person has that's greed which is a much
more wholesome sin because simply
wanting what someone has can Inspire us
it can fuel our own ambition it can even
motivate us to improve ourselves and
sometimes people call that Envy but it's
not really Envy it's emulation or
admiration at worst it's what the Bible
calls coveting he covets Envy is
something darker it's not just wanting
what someone has it's begrudging them
what they have you might even hate the
person you envy and want them to lose
what they have to be humiliated and
destroyed even if their downfall doesn't
benefit you in any way like Satan who is
willing to lose Heaven just despite God
according to the poet John milon it's
going to be 90 minutes of mil jokes kids
so strap in so Envy is malicious it's a
force of Destruction for an example of
the distinction between envy and
emulation think about incels involuntary
celibates these men who can't get
girlfriends and are bitter about it
online it was incels who contributed to
our culture the concept of Chads that is
beautiful wealthy masculine men for
incels taking the red pill means buying
into an ideology which says that women
only want to date Chads or else they
want to marry beta cucks just to take
their beta bucks gas keep gate boss girl
light so if you're an incel you can
either go to the gym and try to become a
Chad that's emulation the aspiration to
attain what another person has or and
this is the more popular option you can
take the black pill which means
believing that Chad hood is genetically
determined at Birth there is no hope no
woman will ever want you and therefore
happiness is impossible you may as well
lie down and rock this mindset of
resentment has inspired so many mass
murders there's an entire Wikipedia
timeline dedicated to tracking them and
the essential motivation for this
violence is Envy the incel's failed
ambition and sense of incurable
predestined inferiority turns venomous
the logic behind the violence is if I
can't get a girlfriend if I can't get
what I want then no one can in the words
of a murderer the day of Retribution is
my attempt to destroy everything I
cannot have but most incels aren't
murderers most of the time Envy is most
harmful to the person who envies the
philosopher Max shayer called it a self-
poisoning of the mind there's a
Christian saying that Envy is the only
sin that gives no pleasure because the
other are fun right greed gluttony lust
that's what I call a good time but Envy
is misery though I wouldn't go so far as
to say it gives no pleasure fire
Festival is an art installation where
mediocre people realize what their lives
would be like without Rich parents yes
Rich Refugee crisis we're living in a
moment of growing inequality and
resentment look around you we've got the
guillotine memes we've got edgy teens
tweeting Eat the Rich and none of this
is new the slogan Eat the Rich actually
originates with the philosopher of the
French Revolution Jaa Gabor who
supposedly said when the people have no
more to eat they will uh Eat the Rich
and fair enough it's a good source of
protein but take it from me kids
cannibalism is one of those tricky
things it's hard to do just once you
develop a taste for it it's like they
say at NA meetings once You' wor you
just want more also who counts as the
rich am I the rich I certainly hope so
cuz I want you to
eat stop it see this is why I quit
Academia if I was a professor I'd have
to behave myself and I don't want to
behave myself I want to be bad do you
want to be bad with me let's be bad
[Music]
so you might think that Envy is simply
the product of inequality and that
societies that have more inequality have
more Envy I used to assume that too but
the more I think about it the more I
realize that might not be true Envy is a
basic part part of human nature it
exists in all societies and all economic
systems and it begins anytime two or
more people start comparing themselves
part two the desire for mommy's
milk according to Sigman Freud or as I
call him daddy daddy the first stage of
human development is the oral stage in
which the primary concern is oral
gratification which is of course
provided by Mommy milkies am I doing too
much I'll to just a little bit so look I
get that a lot of people are skeptical
about Freud and it's true he was a bit
of a crackpot Coke fiend who had some
zeny ideas like penis envy maybe there's
transgender men who experiened that but
I don't think it's a basic fact of the
female condition as for castration
anxiety is that a dare because I take
that personally I'm giving it a very
serious consideration doctor but I feel
like even when Freud is wrong he's often
at least on to something like with the
edus comp
it's not that you literally desire your
mother right that would be weird it's
more that you desire an archetype mother
right mommy you guys get it jenzy Tik
Tok lesbians get it they're the ones who
got me started on this mil [ __ ] I'm a
reverse socres I've been corrupted by
the young my innocent and delicate
Nature has been defiled so Freud says
that in the first two years of life
libido is primarily focused on mommy's
milk and it's also in this stage that
Envy first emerges so I was the oldest
child in my family and I was less than 2
years old when my brother was born so I
don't remember this because I was
one-year-old but my family tells me that
when my brother was born I was just
insanely jealous oh and I guess now is a
good time to discuss the difference
between jealousy and envy Scholars agree
that there is a difference and
usually and usually they describe the
difference in one of two ways the first
is that jealousy is defensive it's a
kind of protectiveness over what is
rightfully yours whereas Envy is
offensive it's resentment over what
someone else has that you lack and the
second difference is that Envy is
between two people the envier and the
envied whereas jealousy typically
involves three people as in romantic
jealousy where you have the subject the
Romantic object and then the Rival and
the subject is jealous of the Rival
because they're protective of their
relationship with the Romantic object
and that's also the dynamic of sibling
rivalry just substituting the romantic
object for mommy of course in ordinary
English people are always going to say
jealousy when they really mean Envy
probably because jealousy has less
negative connotations and I think it's
pointless to try to fight that like I
wouldn't go around correcting people but
just keep in mind that there is a
difference so sibling rivalry is that
Envy or jealousy well I think it's both
because initially you're defensive of
your privileged only child relationship
with your parents but a new baby often
gets more attention at least in your
paranoid toddler brain and you might be
envious of that and in romantic jealousy
you may also Envy the Rival if she has
qualities that you wish you had you know
young kids are little egotists who are
very sensitive to when another child
might be getting preferential treatment
one of the favorite phrases of tiny
babies is it's not fair it's not
fair tell me about it Bambino and I've
got bad news life is not getting any
more fair than this according to the
Bible one of the first events in human
history is the story of Cen
abelos I don't know why I said it in
Spanish I I guess I just thought it
would sound cool was I wrong Cen it just
sounds so much better than Cain Cain and
Abel Cain and Abel God tells Cain and
Abel each to make a sacrifice and then
God prefers Ables you know cuz God loves
meat then in an act of malicious toward
Abel and spite towards God the Father
Cen kills his younger brother in my
earliest memories of my brother I
already loved him and I don't remember
the Envy so I guess I wasn't a Cain Cen
so I must have somehow worked through
this without resorting to murder H Freud
says that the older siblings Envy of the
younger leads to a recognition of
impotence because at first you selfishly
want to be the special most loved child
but you see see that your parents love
your sibling just as much as you and
you're powerless to do anything about it
so your ambition to superiority fails
and so you have no choice but to repress
your ambition to superiority as well as
your envy and the result of that
repression is what we could call herd
Instinct solidarity this feeling of
identifying with a group the equal
siblings and as you get older the herd
Instinct evolves into feelings about
Justice Duty imunity and equality but
Freud thought these feelings retain a
vestage of repressed Envy if I can't be
the favorite if I can't have special
privileges then no one can and from
these observations Freud made the
generalization social justice means that
we deny ourselves many things so that
others may have to do without them as
well okay so we don't want other people
to have anything we can't have so we
enviously insist on equality as a
defense against the greater prosperity
of others now I don't think I completely
agree with that like I think Freud is
definitely on to something here but
don't some of our community feelings
also come from a place of genuine care
for other
people I cared for someone
once
BR well we'll come back to that later
let's put a pin in me for now a a pin in
it for now and Freud I mean let's put a
pin in
Freud in a 1966 book titled Envy a
theory of social behavior the
sociologist Helmut shook argued that
rather than being that is a very German
name Helmut he putting me in a German
mood sweetie H Min
leous video I just get worse at German
every year shook argued that rather than
being the result of social or e economic
inequality Envy is a universal across
all human societies including very
egalitarian ones for example in tribal
and Village cultures around the world
there's often a concept of black magic
or witchcraft which are thought to be
used by envious people to bewitch the
ones they Envy you're probably familiar
with the concept of the evil eye which
originates in ancient Greece or maybe
even earlier than that cultures all over
the world today understand the evil eye
as a kind of curse cast by the malignant
gaze of an envious person now you might
be thinking that sounds superstitious
but I actually think the concept of the
evil eye reveals a more sophisticated
awareness of envy and of the social
danger that it poses you've probably
seen these amulets around there's an
emoji for them now which are supposed to
protect against the evil eye it's called
a Nazar which comes from the Arabic word
for sight or surveillance similar to the
origin of the English word envy which is
the Latin Invidia which just means to
look at so there's an agreement across
cultures that Envy is related to sight
the malevolent gaze the evil eye and
these amulets show that a lot of people
are afraid of being envied and want to
protect themselves I was just watching
this Turkish YouTube channel with an
episode on the evil eye and the host
explains that for Muslims it's customary
to
say or God has wed it when admiring a
person or object you know to avoid
unintentionally cursing them I love that
it's like no end like no homo but no
Envy masah the top comment on that video
says you want to protect yourself from
the evil green ey monster well don't
tell others about your ideas goals or
wishes don't be flaunting your
accomplishments on social media or
posting pictures of your children that's
how you avoid being jinxed see this is
where Kim Kardashian went wrong with her
birthday post clearly no one in the
Kardashian Cinematic Universe has ever
heard of the evil eye wait I thought
these people were Armenian why haven't
they heard of the oh okay never mind
every piece of media they've ever
produced is about flaunting an enviable
lifestyle this is a particularly
American thing most Americans have no
concept of the fear of Envy like there's
advertisements here that literally
promise if you buy this exclusive luxury
vibrator you'll be the Envy of all your
friends as if it's a good thing to be
envied oh but it is not if people Envy
you they gossip about you right they
seee over your successes and celebrate
your misfortunes being envied is
basically the opposite of being loved so
why would anyone want to be envied well
it's a contradiction of human nature on
the one hand we need to be loved but
then there's this other Drive in us this
like homeric striving for fame and glory
and riches which is kind of In conflict
with our need to be loved in a past
guilded age there were stories like
Citizen Cane and son said Boulevard
which warned what a sad and lonely thing
success can become in ancient Democratic
Athens there was a practice called ostra
kismos which is the origin of the
English word ostracism ostracism was a
procedure where the Athenians would
assemble and each person would write the
name of a person they wanted to
ostracize on a pottery Shard called an
ostron and whoever got the most votes
would simply be banished from the city
for 10 years no questions
asked I love the ancient world things
were so direct often this was used to
remove someone who is becoming too
prominent or too arrogant or just
annoying according to Plutarch I'm just
going to read this from Wikipedia and
one anecdote about aristedes known as
aristes the just who was ostracized in
482 an illiterate citizen not
recognizing him came up to ask him to
write the name aristes on his ostron
when aristes asked why the man replied
it was because he was sick of hearing
him being called the
just it's good it's so good see this is
why the idea of cancel culture is absurd
this has been going on since the dawn of
civilization people in most cultures not
all but most cultures understand that
being envied is a massive social
liability so it's best not to draw too
much attention to yourself according to
a tamel saying the tree that bears fruit
will be stoned this is sometimes called
tall poppy s because the tallest poppies
in the garden will be cut shook argues
that the fear of Envy is a major
inhibiting force in many Societies in
Haiti G Simpson found that a peasant
will seek to disguise his true economic
position by purchasing several smaller
Fields rather than one larger piece of
land for the same reason he will not
wear good clothes he does this
intentionally to protect himself against
the envious black magic of his neighbors
now this kind of thing is not unheard of
in America like I've known people from
seriously wealthy families who move to
the city and they dress like gutter
punks like they're trying to pass as
poor but in general Americans don't
openly acknowledge fear of Envy in the
way many other cultures do and I don't
think that's an accident We're a nation
of showoffs and so the taboo against
discussing Envy is related to our whole
National ethos of shoving our wealth in
everyone's face but though the fear of
Envy isn't widely talked about or
admitted here it's definitely still
there only repressed confined to the
realm of dreams and
art in the movie Black Swan Nina is a
Perfection obsessed ballerina who
achieves her dream of getting the lead
role in Swan Lake after which her life
and mind are totally unraveled by fear
of Envy Black Magic Black Swan at first
we see how Nina's success comes at the
very real cost of being envied by her ex
ballerina Mother by the other girls in
the company and by the former lead
ballerina she's placed did you suck
his not all of us have
to I love wiona ryer so much I love
Natalie pman so much I love milauna so
much I just like women where's my
where's my shock wand stop it stop
standing but reasonable fear of Envy
becomes paranoia as nah begins
hallucinating Black Swan doppelgangers
and is seduced by bisexual demon munes
who's trying to steal her role you got
to watch out for those bisexual demons
they'll get you did you have some sort
of lesy wet dream about me stop you
could argue that nah is actually
suffering a kind of self Envy where she
envies the disinhibited sexually
liberated corrupted part of herself
that's capable of adult eroticism and
also of dancing the Black Swan so she
imagines that part of herself as an
envious rival who's trying to replace
her it's like her mind is suit between
two impulses there's her dominant White
Swan impulse which we could call the
Squidward personality perfectionistic
and orderly but reserved priggish stiff
and then there's her repressed Black
Swan impulse which we could call the
SpongeBob personality intuitive chaotic
ecstatic in SpongeBob SquarePants the
character Squidward is fundamentally a
figure of Envy stemming from failed
ambition hello you've reached the house
of unrecognized talent Squidward aspires
to Artistic ACH achievement but remains
in mediocrity partly because of his
overly dry doctrinaire attitude towards
art SpongeBob is Squidward's social
equal they're literally neighbors and
they both work the same fast food
service job for the same exploitative
capitalist but SpongeBob is a mardian
intuitive genius who's able to transform
the most mundane activities blowing
bubbles flipping burgers into a kind of
aesthetic Rapture Squidward intensely
envies SpongeBob's uninhibited joy and
intuitive creativity but he can't admit
that Envy to himself so he convinces
himself that what he's really feeling is
contempt snobbish disdain for
SpongeBob's childish behavior what the
people want is culture not dancing
bubbles though deep down Squidward
really wants what SpongeBob has it's
beautiful uh I mean uh which we see when
he can't help himself from blowing
bubbles or when he trades away all of
his possessions for the chewing gum
rapper that in SpongeBob's hands was a
source of infinite entertainment a lot
of people my age who watched SpongeBob
as a kid rewatch it now and are
horrified to discover that they identify
with Squidward whereas as children they
identified with SpongeBob well you
either die a SpongeBob or you live long
enough to see yourself become the
Squidward
future and there's a pain in becoming
Squidward which is usually explained as
the disappointing drudgery of adult life
or simply loss of childhood I would
argue that Envy of childhood is the
distinctive squid wardian emotion
Squidward are we saying that word are we
really saying that word out loud to an
audience of
millions okay it's basically the same
dynamic as solar's Envy of Mozart in
amadas oh my God the evil eye killed
Mozart you got to watch out for that one
kids if a mysterious stranger shows up
on your doorstep at midnight asking you
to compose a re a math for your own
father just say no so in sponge medas
Mozart pants we have a diligent those
stuffy wannabe envying the effortless
playfulness of the spontaneous
[Music]
genius so Squidward's Envy of SpongeBob
is well it's Apollo's Envy of dionis
look if we were to view SpongeBob
SquarePants through the philosophy of
Friedrich Nisha stay with me ladies I
have an angle here we could say that
Squidward represents what Nicha called
the apollonian impulse while SpongeBob
represents the dionan Nicha thought
there were two conflicting artistic
drives in the human personality the
apollonian named after the Greek god
Apollo is the drive towards self-control
order logic morality and the dionan
named after dionis is the drive toward
intoxication
frenzy passion intuition both SpongeBob
and Amadeus present these two drives in
conflict with the apollonian envying the
dionan of course this is a
misrepresentation of how art is actually
created because n's whole point is that
you need a balance of the two drives in
reality you cannot have a pure dionysian
artist like SpongeBob because creating
good art requires at least some level of
discipline and ordering see it is is all
in the technique otherwise you're just
some drunk idiot with a guitar get off
the stage so Black Swan is in a way
actually more realistic in order to give
the perfect performance nah has to unify
her fragmented personality and dance
both swans resolving the envious rivalry
between her two artistic
impulses that was
perfect another movie about fear of
envious B Arina
doppelgangers can you guess it is Jordan
peele's 2019 horror film us which
dramatizes the repressed economic guilt
and fear of the American middle class we
meet the Wilsons a moderately affluent
family with a vacation house and a boat
along with the tyers a slightly better
off white family whom the Wilson's Envy
other new car right he had to do it he
just had to get that thing to [ __ ] with
me too one night the Wilson's vacation
home is invaded by a family of their own
monstrous doppelgangers red the only
doppelganger who can speak explains that
her family is metaphysically Tethered to
the Wilsons living wretched and
destitute versions of their lives in a
Lial back room's underworld it's super
[ __ ] Lial I'm on ambient at an AA
meeting not again once upon a time there
was a girl and the girl had a shadow the
two were connected tethered together
when the girl ate her food was given to
her warm and tasty but when the shadow
was hungry she had to eat rabbit raw and
bloody we later find out that all over
the US o us spells us hey that's the
title of the movie oh the tethered have
risen up to kill their privileged
doppelgangers and to link arms across
the country in a dark parody of the real
world 198 86 homelessness fundraiser
Hands Across America so my reading of us
is that it's an expression of middle
class guilt about privilege and fear of
Envy it's not a movie about the working
class if it was a movie about the
working class then the working class
would be able to speak human languages
and would not be scary monsters who make
animal
sounds and Stager around like zombies
this is a movie about the anxious middle
class's nightmare of the working class
US represents in a self-aware way what
other home invasion movies represent
unconsciously the fear of the envious
poor of revolution of slave revolt tell
me you did not just reference home alone
but us diverges from other home invasion
movies by not just being fearful about
the underclass but also guilty the idea
of the tethered underclass represents
life as a zero sum game where every
moment of your happiness is bought with
someone else's suffering it's an
incredibly guilty fantasy an
internalization of the Blackmagic logic
of people who blame their own
misfortunes on the people they Envy as
shook puts it my neighbor's Harvest can
only have turned out better than mine
because he has somehow succeeded in
reducing Mine by black magic so the fear
of envy and the guilt of success are
repressed in American culture but they
still find expression in movies Jordan
Peele is kind of like the Charles
Dickens of the 21st century us actually
reminds me of A Christmas Carol a story
about the guilt of the rich if ever
there was one you know Scrooge is
visited by ghosts who show him how
wretched and sad the lives of his
employees are and how he'll die alone
and hated by everyone and his funeral is
only attended by businessmen on the
condition that lunch is provided Dickens
was truly the master of scaring the rich
straight so maybe fear of Envy can serve
a softly regulatory function by m
motivating charity and generosity in the
rich but in general I'm suspicious of
Envy as a motivation for politics cuz
remember the basic logic of Envy is if I
can't have it then no one can which is a
purely negative destructive style of
thinking it's taking privileges away not
for the material benefit of the
underprivileged but merely for the
psychological satisfaction of the
envious person and that's even worse
when you consider that Envy is
subjective it doesn't necessarily Target
objective power and privilege so Envy in
politics is Not By Any Means relegated
to the left conservative politics is
brimming With Envy like in this debate
about forgiving student loan debt you
often hear people say I had to pay my
student loans so they should too debt
forgiveness is not fair the logic here
is since I didn't get my student debt
forgiven no one should it's
intergenerational Envy which is a pretty
common thing usually older Generations
envying the young kids these days have
it so easy when I was young we ate nails
for breakfast and sent text messages on
the Pony Express the feeling is
basically it's not fair that kids these
days don't have to suffer like I
suffered or think about the concept of a
Welfare Queen which openly reeks of envy
and white resentment or the way
conservatives talk about immigration
it's all this envious suspicion about
illegal immigrants sneaking in and
getting government handouts without
having to pay taxes I had to work hard
for my money so I should these people
get a free ride not that that's what
being an illegal immigrant is actually
like accept in the imagination of people
who Envy them Envy is felt more
intensely by prideful people so it's
especially sharp when it targets people
who are supposed to be beneath you the
Jewish radical feminist Andrea dorin
made what I think is a pretty compelling
argument that both anti-Semitism and
misogyny are partly rooted in Envy she
quotes a bigoted argument made by the
wife killing protagonist of tolstoy's
story The czer Sonata Who resents that
women and Jews find a kind of
paradoxical power in their own
oppression just like the Jews as they
pay us back for their oppression by
Financial domination so it is with women
ah you want us to be traitors only all
right as traitors we will dominate you
say the Jews ah you want us to be merely
objects of sensuality all right as
objects of sensuality we will enslave
you dworin explains this dominance of
men by women is experienced by the men
is real emotionally real sexually real
psychologically real it emerges as the
reason for the Wrath of the misogynist
the woman appears to control sex The man
needs it this causes his rage at her
perceived power over him women control
access to what men want which gives
women a kind of indirect power that some
men Envy they Envy the sexual power of
women it doesn't matter to the
misogynist that especially at the time
tolto was writing women objectively have
less power in society than men he envies
women because they have what he desires
likewise it didn't matter to viar anti
semites that Jewish people were a
marginalized minority anti-Semitism is
often rooted in an envious obsession
with the disproportionate influence and
affluence of Jewish people it is not the
absolute differences between men which
feed Envy but subjective perception the
Optics of
Envy magic mirror on the wall who's the
CEST of them all
Thou Art [ __ ] my queen but hold a lovely
maid I
see oh yes it's me what in a way I'm
kind of just in the beginning of this
whole transition you know like a young
little girl going through all these
things having a sleepover with the girls
what do we do on a sleepover do we have
like pillow fights and all that stuff
alas she is more [ __ ] than
thee my [ __ ] stunting on the gram has
come to
[Music]
nothing the classic 1937 Disney movie
Snow White in the wicked mil is the
story of a quote Vain and wicked Queen
who obsessively envies the beauty of her
own stepdaughter are you sure this was
for children every day the mil Queen ask
the mirror who's the fairest one of all
and the mirror responds that the queen
is the fairest till one day it says the
stepdaughter Snow White is the fairest
which sends the queen into an envious
Fury resulting in a series of bizarre
murder attempts so first of all can we
talk plot holes ding are we really
supposed to believe that this is more
beautiful than this uh ding isn't Snow
White like 12 years old what's going on
Walt why don't you take a seat maybe
she's not 12 I don't know it's hard to
tell cuz she's constantly surrounded by
manlets but she's just so boring and the
queen is such a baddie step on my throat
mother this is a horny video well yeah
cuz I quit riding that brown tiger I can
feel the pulse back in my veins so
despite the Injustice done to its lead
mil Snow White does illustrate some
interesting things about Envy once again
we have black magic and Witchcraft as an
expression of Envy we have the age
difference intergenerational Envy the
Envy of Youth it kind of reminds me of
those Millennial women who hit 30 and
suddenly feel a need to rage against
jenz pretty counterproductive since if
you're worried about seeming old
complaining about the youths is probably
not helping your case Gorge you might
wonder if there's also jealousy involved
with the evil queen like is she worried
that the king is going to fall in love
with his own daughter well I don't think
so because we never even see the king
the queen doesn't mention him it's not
about the king so there's no romantic
jealousy involved it's just one woman
envying another woman over Beauty for
its own sake we stand a beell test
passing movie about women hating each
other gate keep gas girl gate girl gas
keep light boss in fact in the original
brother's Grim version the queen first
tries killing Snow White with beauty
accessories poisoning a comb and lacing
her to death with a corset I wish I
could die that way sh what's really
striking is the pure kamakazi malignity
of it all this queen who we know is
obsessed with her look is willing to
transform herself with witchcraft into
an ugly old hag just to give Snow White
the poisoned apple and the queen
disguising herself as an old hag
parallels Satan disguising himself as a
serpent I mean you could actually argue
that the queen is simply a Persona of
Satan it's Paradise Lost all over again
which also happens to be the title of my
Memoir the queen is incredibly Petty
because even according to the again
wrong and tasteless mirror she's still
the second most beautiful woman in the
world how could someone so close to the
top of the hierarchy still be consumed
by Envy well basically because that's
how Envy works it's Petty it's
subjective and it's indifferent to the
magnitude of the inequality or to the
absolute position on the overall
hierarchy so you can be the second best
in the world and still be obsessively
envious of the one person who may barely
even be above you in fact there's
studies showing that Olympic silver
medalists are actually less satisfied
with their prize than bronze medalists
probably because the bronze medalist is
just happy to be on the podium at all
while the silver medalist is so close to
first they can't help but wonder what if
humans form our sense of identity and
self-worth not by comparing ourselves to
any absolute standard but by comparing
ourselves to each other and we're more
likely to compare ourselves to the
people who are are around us than we are
to people who are far away we could call
this the proximity effect of Envy we're
more likely to envy people who are close
to us or similar to us especially people
we're in competition with that's why
social media is such a nightmare it's an
incubator of Envy because it puts
everyone next to everyone else so we're
all being compared all in competition
and it can destroy your self-esteem
because you're comparing your actual
life to these idealized images and it
also turns public figures into lightning
rods for Envy because of the numeric
visibility of popularity and success
it's a perverse consequence of the
proximity effect that Envy within an
oppressed class is often more venomous
and obsessive than Envy for the
oppressor so for example in Snow White
and Black Swan you have women envying
other women because women are often in
competition with each other and I know
it's kind of a misogynistic trope in
media there's constant portrayals of
vain and envious women jealous [ __ ]
fighting over men over youth over Beauty
it's like drag queen femininity Death
Becomes Her
femininity on
guard [ __ ] so yeah it's kind of a
misogynistic Trope but how do I put this
delicately sometimes reality is
misogynistic like when my eyelash won't
stay glued on the patriarchy's mockin
naations are clearly to blame in her
1976 essay trashing the Dark Side of
Sisterhood feminist Joe Freeman wrote
about her ostracism from within the
women's movement I've been watching for
years with increasing dismay as the
movement consciously destroys anyone
within it who stands out in any way and
she quotes a speech by fellow feminist
and Selma Delio and who do they attack
achievement or accomplishment of any
kind would seem to be the worst crime do
anything that every other woman secretly
or otherwise feels she could do just as
well and you're in for it you are
immediately labeled a thrill-seeking
opportunist a ruthless mercenary out to
make her Fame and Fortune over the dead
bodies of selfless sisters who have
buried their abilities and sacrificed
their Ambitions for the greater glory of
feminism Freeman speculates the primary
reason there have been so few great
women blank is not merely that greatness
has been undeveloped or unrecognized but
that women women exhibiting potential
for achievement are punished by both
women and men the fear of success is
quite rational when one knows that the
consequence of achievement is hostility
and not praise so at no point in this
essay does Joe Freeman use the word envy
but as usual Envy is right below the
surface causing all the trouble so
Freeman is describing how people from
marginalized groups whose ambition
raises them above the typical limits AC
by marginalization are often ostracized
from their own communities but she has
no causal explanation for why this
happens I have an explanation the
explanation is envy and women are more
likely to Envy other women trans women
are more likely to Envy other trans
women oh God am I really going to go
there if we did this topic Justice this
video would be N9 centuries long on
guard [ __ ] a lot of people assume that
trans women Envy CIS women and there is
some truth to that there definitely was
a time in my life when I used to Envy
CIS women for being CIS women but now I
kind of just don't even allow myself to
have the thought what if I were a
ciswoman so in a way because becoming a
ciswoman is impossible it's unobtainable
I actually Envy CIS women less so trans
women are more likely to Envy other
trans women because of the proximity
effect and because another transwoman
represents an actual possibility of what
I a trans woman could become she's a
standard to which I could plausibly
compare myself here's a post someone
made on my own fan subreddit am I the
only one who finds it hard to watch
trans creators before I realized I was a
trans woman I [ __ ] loved people like
Contra points Nix Speers and other trans
creators but ever since I realized I was
trans I just get this angry resentful
feeling in the pit of my stomach
whenever I get recommended any of these
videos I seriously loved Contra points
but whenever I try to watch any of her
videos I just want to scream I have this
feeling toward passing trans people in
general I feel such hatred for them and
I don't know why am I just a toxic
person well sweetie you're not a toxic
person at least not any worse than
anyone else it's just that human nature
is a toxic person and that angry
resentful feeling in the pit of your
stomach that makes you want to scream
and feel such a hatred has a name and
the name is Envy I actually admire the
person who wrote this post because
they're doing the best that any of us
can do really which is noticing the
feeling without endorsing the feeling I
wish that more people could feel things
without rushing to a rational defense of
the feeling it isn't rationality itself
often simply the attempt to make our
feelings contagious sometimes people
have no self-awareness about it at all
for example there's a certain kind of uh
Boomer transsexual who complains that
when I transitioned I had to go through
rigorous Medical gatekeeping but kids
these days just BS on in and walk out
with hormones it's intergenerational
Envy trans Edition it was hard for me so
it should be hard for everyone like the
student debt debate if I can't have it
no one can and look I do have sympathy
and admiration for older trans people
like being Trans in 2021 is already the
maximum level of adversity that I can
handle I cannot imagine how hard it was
to do this in the80s however the pain of
Envy is not a valid argument Envy is not
sacred rage and the malignant demands of
envious people should be ignored God
this community the constant competition
the Envy the cringing it makes it really
hard to get along with other trans
people oh speaking of which gay tangent
everybody gay tangent Envy presents kind
of a unique problem to samesex attracted
people because of the increased risk of
envying the very people you're attracted
to I want to the ones I envy I envy you
know it's the classic do I want you or
do I want to be you problem I've heard
feminine queer women say they could
never date another fem because they're
worried they would just end up envying
her so dating masculine women solves
that problem because having separate
roles separate Aesthetics separate
categories helps to avert proximity Envy
between partners
unfortunately I am not that smart
basically I am attracted to femininity
but I also want to embody a kind of
feminine archetype myself I'm not
masculine and I don't want to be you
know I used to think I'd only want to
date another trans women because of the
mutual understanding but I've kind of
realized that at this point it may
actually be more psychologically healthy
for me to open up to dating CIS women I
used to not want to do that because I
was afraid it would make me feel like a
man but at this point honestly just be a
man whatever it's fine as a dry Queen
once said I'm more of a man than you'll
ever be and more more of a woman than
you'll ever have yes God can we get the
tequila out of the frame please I think
at a distance it's okay to indulge the
attraction emulation ambiguity but if
you want to actually have a relationship
with someone you have to make up your
mind that you desire this woman and you
do not want to be her because think
about it from the other perspective what
could be less attractive than someone
who literally wants to be you teacher
make her stop copying me like as much as
I joke every episode about how Buffalo
Bill is an iconique trans Legend you
don't want to date that [ __ ] imagine
trying to date Eve from All About Eve
pass hard pass so if you're a queer
woman or a queer anything honestly and
you find yourself envying your partner
my advice is stop overthinking a good
situation an enviable woman wanted to be
with you so sit back relax and enjoy the
clout I get it though it's it's comp at
you know we're all supposed to proudly
affirm what we truly desire but how do
you know what you truly desire do I want
mommy or do I want to be the
mommy yes just yes anyway let's go back
to talking about Sigman Freud the mother
have took over
completely do I look okay is my head on
straight so we keep running into this
avoidance of the word envy and people
especially cannot seem to notice when
they themselves are feeling envious like
that person who puzzled over the angry
resentful feeling in the pit of their
stomach without being able to name what
they were feeling there's two reasons
why people are usually in denial about
their own Envy one is guilt and the
other is shame shame shame because
admitting to yourself that you envy
someone implies that you feel in
inferior to them which is shameful it
wounds the ego and guilt because Envy is
malicious if you envy someone you may
feel angry and miserable about their
success and good fortune and you may
wish to see them ruined or brought down
that's cruel and antisocial it goes
against most ideas of morality and it's
a thought that's usually not socially
acceptable to admit so Envy is shameful
guilty and socially unacceptable and we
deal with that by suppressing it from
our awareness but it is still there and
in order to maintain the denial we have
to convince ourselves that this angry
resentful feeling in the pit of our
stomach is actually something else think
about how in SpongeBob Squidward shows
contempt for SpongeBob's childishness
for blowing bubbles for having fun at
work when in fact Squidward envies
SpongeBob's uninhibited joy and
intuitive creativity but he can't allow
himself to have the thought that he
envies SpongeBob because that would mean
recognizing the intolerably shameful
truth that he feels inferior to
SpongeBob so what he does instead is
convince himself that what he really is
is a refined sophisticate scoffing at
this childish fool how did I ever get
surrounded by such loser
neighbors we could call this Envy to
contempt sublimation sublimation is a
psychoanalytic term which means that you
transform an ego wounding feeling or
socially unacceptable longing into
something more ego flattering or
socially acceptable so the classic
example used by Freud is the
transformation of sexual urges of erotic
energy into creative expression it's
like the founder of the noof fap
movement Lady Gaga once said I have this
weird thing that if I sleep with someone
they're going to take my creativity from
me through my uh so according to Freud
the vast majority of erotic longings can
never be fulfilled tell me about it
sigment misery uh but there's a positive
side to this supposedly which is that
you can sublimate your erotic longings
into a more socially acceptable
productivity so you know instead of
flicking the bean maybe you write novels
about thirsty vampires or for that
matter philosophical treatises about the
will to power but we'll get to you Freud
thought that Civilization itself is
built at the cost of our instin
instincts most of which we have to
sacrifice in order to live in a society
so like erotic impulses I think Envy can
be sublimated which is what's happening
when it becomes contempt another example
is the blog mcmansion hell which makes
fun of the tasteless architecture of
suburban ostentatious trash I would
argue that part of the fun of this blog
is the pleasure and relief of looking
down at the rich because looking
enviously up at the rich is painful ful
it makes you feel inferior and a way to
alleviate that pain is to sublimate envy
and pretend that you're an aristocratic
aete scoffing at the vulgar Taste of the
arav eist these flying buttresses are an
extremely po taste another example is
shit-talking plastic surgery I once
heard a trans woman say at least I don't
look like a botched sex doll the subtext
is there's a certain kind of transwoman
influencer who lives in LA and has a lot
of cosmetic surgery to achieve a
doll-like aesthetic but it costs a lot
of money to look like this and a lot of
trans women can't afford surgeries that
they want and one way to cope with
frustrated desire is to convince
yourself that the thing that's Out Of
Reach is not worth having anyway see
also the discourse on Twitter about how
passing is transphobic there's an
ancient Greek Fable where a fox wants
some grapes but he can't reach the vine
so he walks away bitterly and says well
the grapes are transphobic anyway anyway
the cisgender version of this is maybe
the not like other girls meme which is
classic Envy to contempt sublimation the
Trope is usually that other girls are
popular and [ __ ] they have fake tans
and fake nails they like partying and
makeup and stupid music for idiots but
I'm quirky and real I listen to Pink
Floyd and read books and eat lots of
pizza late at night alone and sad
there's usually a subtext of anxiety
about inferior prity the other girls
being more socially accepted feminine
and put together a lot of times the
other girls don't even exist right
they're a media construct of idealized
Womanhood like where are these other
girls who've never eaten pizza and enjoy
wearing makeup at 900 a.m. on a Saturday
morning are they between the sofa
cushions did you put them in with the
other laundry are the other girls in the
room with us right now so the feeling of
inferiority toward the other girls is
reframed as a kind of contemptuous
hipster super superiority which is
really just an ego defensive Persona of
resentment like Janice in meain girls
she's not even really a lesbian she's
Lebanese Lebanese Regina got confused
and then she dances with a boy at the
end and is readmitted into girlhood uh
thank you for that Tina Fe that's very
helpful great another way we can reframe
feelings of envious inferiority is by
transforming them into moral superiority
moral superiority often being The Refuge
of of people with nothing better to feel
Superior about we don't have to feel
guilty or ashamed of Envy if we convince
ourselves that what we're actually
experiencing is Justified legitimate
hatred so for example think of the
morality around sexuality part 69 [ __ ]
yeah what are you going to do about it
cancel me on
guard [ __ ] why does everyone hate [ __ ]
so much [ __ ] never did nothing wrong to
nobody open sexual promiscuity is in a
way analogous to opulence you're
conspicuously enjoying something that
other people want but may not be able to
get many cultures have Norms about
modesty for example expecting women to
cover their hair in public this is
usually explained as prophylaxis against
male lust but I wonder if it also serves
to prevent a more generalized Envy which
female Beauty has a way of attracting
men often [ __ ] shame because they want
to control female sexuality and by
female sexuality I do mean male
sexuality because often what they're
really struggling to control is their
own desire but [ __ ] shaming is also done
pretty viciously by women to each other
and that's a complicated thing it's more
than just Envy sometimes it comes from a
sense that a woman who's having casual
sex with a lot of men is compromising
the collective sex withholding power of
the group almost like she's crossing a
picket line but there's also sometimes a
resentment that a woman who's showing
skin is using her body to get unearned
attention and that smells like Envy to
me I don't use my body to get attention
so no one should the repressed feeling
is maybe I'm a little jealous that she's
getting all this attention by posting
thirst traps but you don't think that
you think I am above this because I am
chased I have class I am a feminist I
would also suggest a accusing her of
pandering to the male gaze that's of
course the feminist way of calling
someone a low down hob skank so again we
have Envy to contempt sublimation and
often the contempt is moral virtuous the
psychological need to convince ourselves
that Envy is morality can become so
strong that we actually start inventing
things to be outraged about take for
instance the tendency to imagine that
the wealthy and Powerful are enjoying
wild satanic orgies and indulging all
the Forbidden salacious Pleasures that
we ourselves are denied like qanon these
conspiracy theorists who want us to
imagine Hillary Clinton reclining in a
Garden of Earthly Delights sampling the
pleasures of
aees live laugh love that for her Envy
is very imaginative when it comes to the
hedonistic extravagance of the envied
let's talk about Marie Antoinette the
queen of France who was guillotined by
the revolution if you know one thing
about Marie Antoinette it's probably
that when she heard about a famine where
the people had no bread she infamously
responded let them eat
cake what an evil [ __ ] how could she
say that
well she didn't she never said it it's a
lie the phrase let them eat cake
originally let them eat Brios first
appeared in Russo's confessions written
in 177 65 when Marie Antoinette was 9
years old Russo attributed the line to a
great princess probably no one ever said
this it's kind of like how the most
famous photo of Paris Hilton is the one
where she's wearing a stop being poor
t-shirt what an evil [ __ ] how could she
wear that well she didn't it's
photoshopped the actual shirt said stop
being desperate Envy likes to fabricate
the Diabolical crime of its enemies I
assume to compliment the helenistic
extravagance I mean what is a Disney
villain if not an opulent homosexual
seen Through The Eyes of the envious see
how I do I'm going to try lowering the
iso cuz it's so bright in here now okay
well it's a much lower ISO what if I get
another light over here that's what this
channel is really about one biological
female's quest to create a harmonious
color story in the Years leading up to
and during the French Revolution Marie
Antoinette was constantly defamed in
these sleazy tabloids called libel is
the same route as the English word liel
the often pornographic libel depicted
the queen as a bisexual demon who was
constantly having drunken orgies and
sexually manipulating everyone around
her all of which is very interesting but
none of which is true the historian
Robert Daron called it an avalanche of
defamation that has no parallel in the
history of vilification this woman took
the blame the moral blame for the
structural failings of a broken economic
system and by the time she was brought
before the Revolutionary tribunal in
1793 the actual person Marie Antoinette
had long ago been overshadowed by the
lialis caricature of her now there was
maybe one good reason for executing the
former Queen which is that the
legitimacy of your new Republic is a
little more secure when you don't have
living monarchs hanging around someone
better tell the English but the the
problem with that reasoning is it has
nothing to do with whether or not the
queen deserved to die and beheading a
recently widowed mother of two in front
of a jeering crowd for political
expediency might weigh a little heavy on
the conscience so the revolution had to
convince themselves that the queen
deserved it which was pretty easy after
Decades of again false and defamatory
gossip in her biography of mar
Antoinette Antonia Frasier describes how
the prison guards separated Marie from
her 8-year-old son who they plied with
alcohol and groomed into accusing his
own mother of incestuous abuse to
justify killing Marie Antoinette they
had to destroy the idea of this woman as
a mother so she was convicted of what
may as well have been crimes against
ethics in games journalism and sent to
the guillotine where her last words were
sorry to the Executioner for stepping on
his foot
uh women stop apologizing challenge this
is what a girl boss winning looks like
so Marie Antoinette literally did
nothing wrong hey how are you an
innocent mil was killed that day and die
for one won't stand for it so look we
have a psychological incentive to
believe that people whom we Envy are
immoral monsters because then we get to
label our hatred and violence toward
them Justice
cruelty generally cannot conceptualize
itself as cruelty and part of the reason
for that is that calling cruelty what it
is takes the fun out of it it reminds me
of the second best day in the history of
Twitter October 1st 2020 the day that
Trump got Co and I'm going to be honest
I have never felt more shot in Fuda in
my entire life well well well if it
isn't the leopards eating people's faces
party having their faces eaten by
[Music]
leopards let's him eat cake like Dan
Savage said it felt like Ronald Reagan
got AIDS the next day I tweeted these
last 24 hours have been the first time
I've genuinely enjoyed Twitter in years
because this website is good for one
thing only reveling in the Cru list of
human impulses and someone responded to
that saying oh my God could you even be
a killjoy but why was I being a killjoy
the Tweet was about how much I was
enjoying it well for most people I guess
not me but for normal people for other
girls cruelty is only pleasurable as
long as they can convince themselves
it's something other than cruelty justce
served so again reason rationality are
often the attempt to publicly
communicate to evangelize our private
feelings and morality ethics and justice
are often put forward as the respectable
public face of private envy
vindictiveness and hatred but is this a
Corruption of morality or have we
stumbled onto something darker what if
morality itself is simply the expression
of some kind of sedom masochistic
urge it's too early for this I mean it's
literally 700 a.m. where I'm filming I
don't know how this keeps happening to
me my head gets cut off one after
afternoon puts me in a philosophical
mood the next morning I I've stayed up
all night and I'm still talking about
the
philosop meow meow hello again kittens
let's talk about Justice ooo I look like
a Supreme Court Justice son so meow it
would actually be fierce if I wasn't you
know I wasn't being meat look I've been
seeing a lot of comments lately along
the lines of Natalie used to do serious
academic arguments now she only cares
about makeup all right you little shits
you want book learning I'm going to
learn you so hard I'm going to learn you
so hard you're going to have a God damn
headache in the morning friederick n
friederick VH n do you mind if I call
you Fred Frederick was a German
philosopher who had a lot to say about
envy and morality but before we get into
that I want to say a little bit about
his life because it's just very funny n
is famous for his concept of the Uber
MCH but Frederick sweet beautiful little
Frederick uh he was not what most people
think of as an Uber mench Frederick was
a chronically ill chronically in pain
nearly blind incel who probably slept
with a prostitute once and got syphilis
and and died life is funny sad but funny
in the introduction to Beyond Good and
Evil the editor says though he prided
himself on being comfortable with women
he does not seem to have have been very
successful in establishing emotionally
satisfying relationships with them which
is hardly
surprising I love when the introduction
to a book is just a brutal roast of the
author who wrote this Rolf Peter hman
you're killing it Rolf you're a Savage I
adore Frederick's books sold a dismal
number of copies in his lifetime what
emerges is a picture of a totally
isolated highly neurotic man who had to
try hard to avoid thinking of himself as
a complete failure
oh he was also doing huge doses of opium
relatable and writing himself
prescriptions for sleeping pills using
the name Dr n Dr n pretty sure I got a
Xanax prescription from that guy once
behind a Dairy Queen n was also a failed
musician and was in love with the
composer rard vogner's
wife the Virgin n Contra the Chad Vagner
you beta
[ __ ] why did I do that can we all agree
that Catgirl n is by far the most cursed
thing I've ever done I just want to Mom
this guy honestly I don't even care that
he's a misogynist his misogyny is simply
too sad to be offended by you know I
think it's interesting that a person
this pathetic can also be a genius whose
name will never die he's someone who had
a lot of reason to be envious and
self-pitying but his philosophy couldn't
be more against that and as a person of
pathetic experience myself that is
unironically kind of inspiring to me so
let's go in in his book on the genealogy
of morality Fred R wants to explain the
origin of the concepts of Good and Evil
under what conditions did man invent the
value judgments good and evil and what
value do they themselves have have they
to now obstructed or promoted human
flourishing hang on my Foods here that's
right you're getting a mukbong sweetie
did you think I was going to sit at this
giant table and not be eating something
this video has been going on more than
an hour so I assume you guys are drunk
by now and we're just kind of hanging
out at this point you guys can't even
see well here I've got a bunch of sushi
and it's my mission to eat all of this
while summarizing the entire life and
work of friederick n Trisha Pedas
nikocado consider this a challenge so
Frederick argues that good and bad not
good and evil that's different we'll get
to that but good and bad were originally
the self-affirming values of people with
power so to be good meant to be powerful
strong beautiful healthy and to be bad
meant to be weak sick common ugly want
to eat one like a cat
and Frederick supports this speculation
with atmology so in a lot of languages
the word that means morally good or
spiritually Noble originally meant Noble
in the sense of aristocratic the
property class like in Buddhism the Arya
saani that's Sanskrit for Noble Truths
Arya means Noble and Arya is used to
mean spiritually Noble but earlier it
meant the aristocracy the rich and
originally it was just the name that a
culture in Northern India gave
themselves
the Aryans I'm really working not to get
soy sauce on this lace This was later
misunderstood by Europeans who wrongly
thought that Aryan Was a
Race oops God damn it God damn it kids
can we not Frederick traces the origin
of the German word gut or the English
good to the name of the Goths no not
those Goths the Scandinavian people who
invaded Europe Frederick calls them the
blonde beasts of prey I like to stalk my
prey in the small hours of the night M
the German word SCH which means bad is
related to SCH which means plain simple
originally common low not aristocratic
not Noble so good and bad were
originally the values of warrior
Aristocrats who were like homeric Heroes
celebrating themselves and Frederick
calls their value system Master morality
this glorification of combat feasting a
athleticism sexual Conquest Beauty the
things were called good and their
opposites weakness impotence ugliness
were called bad the ancient Nobles
worshiped Noble Gods who acted like them
and shared their values I mean if I
created a personal goddess I think we
all know what animal that would be me
and the ancient Egyptians on the same
page so for example Roman Warriors could
worship Mars the god of war and it was
like they were worshiping themselves
they were dumb jocks worshiping Dum jock
Gods well good for them but what about
the people who got shoved into lockers
well Frederick's example and this is
going to create some misunderstandings
later but his example is the Jews who
are colonized by the Romans in Judea and
it's certainly not that the Jews didn't
try to revolt oh they did multiple times
but for several centuries the Romans
were just too powerful no one could stop
them so the question is what happens
psychologically to people who are
oppressed and who lack the power to
overthrow the oppressor well in that
case frustrated vindictiveness builds
over time to become this deep bitterness
which n gave the French name res
resentment in English
we
absolute I don't speak French I just
enjoy making vaguely French
noises I don't like the English but I
like the French even less because
they're always dressed so well and they
speak a sexier language than me stop it
this is your final warning comu good
wine though I'll give them that so
there's a German word n which means Envy
so why is Frederick using this French
term rant what's going on Frederick why
you speaking French are you nervous
you're trying to impress me n must have
said ranti because he thought it was
something different than Envy I think
the difference is resentment and I'm
just going to use the English word so I
don't sound like an [ __ ] resentment
is born not just of wanting what someone
has but of a permanent frustration of
the desire for Revenge it's born of
weakness inability to get revenge now
Revenge itself implies weakness at least
a temporary weakness we say revenge is
best served cold but actually revenge is
only served cold if it's served hot if
someone slaps you and you slap them back
immediately that's retaliation not
Revenge you brought this on yourself
revenge is only a possibility when you
can't retaliate immediately so you
become vindictive you start plotting and
scheming but if you're too weak too
impotent to have any hope of Revenge
then you become resentful so n's
argument is that a person who's too weak
to get material Revenge can instead get
psychological Revenge by creating a new
Morality In Frederick's words the
beginning of the slaves revolt and
morality occurs when
itself turns creative and gives birth to
values this is a little high concept for
a mukbang isn't it what are you doing
Frederick so while master morality says
that good is power riches health and
strength and bad is the opposite slave
of morality the morality of resentment
says blessed are the poor the meek the
sick the powerless this is the good of
slave morality and its opposite is not
the bad but A New Concept the evil and
what is evil well everything that Master
morality says is good power wealth
Conquest sexual
[Music]
satisfaction he's talking about
Christianity here he's not talking about
Judaism but Frederick thinks of
Christianity as the spiritual revenge of
the Jews against the Romans an inversion
of the Empire's values but he also
thinks that slave morality is
fundamentally dishonest it's like the
fox and the grapes not being able to
take revenge is called not wanting to
take revenge it might even be called
forgiveness slave of morality says that
weakness is righteous submission to
people you hate is called obedience
having to wait is called patience
inability to satisfy sexual desire is
called Chastity Purity and so on and
while master immorality is born of
saying yes to yourself as a powerful
Noble Beast of prey slay of morality is
born of saying no to the master and
everything he has that you can't I like
to have my belly rubbed scratch my back
above my tail please I'm going to put
the rest of the fish away because it's
getting warm and I'm full this has not
been a successful mukbang it turns out
that it's actually very difficult to do
a mukbang while talking I should have
thought this through a little harder hm
so slave morality is born of a repressed
desire for Revenge but that desire for
Revenge never completely disappears it's
there for example in the Christian idea
of the last
judgment no need to take revenge against
the wicked my sheep God will do that for
us and in the
meantime being weak is good actually I
find this book thrilling to read
honestly and I'm not easily thrilled
especially not by philosophers I think
this book in particular gets me because
especially if you a raised Christian
this is so the opposite of everything
you were ever taught to believe that it
almost feels like dirty should I be
reading this is this allowed cuz even if
you're not religious most of us still
agree with a lot of Christian morality
like yeah Jesus was a good guy blessed
are the meek sure but then Frederick
comes along and he's like morality is
just a cope for frustrated
vindictiveness and you're like I need to
lie down where's my smelling salt
[Music]
but wait there's more this gets even
darker n thinks that over the last two
Millennia of European history slave
morality has triumphed St Paul made
Christianity marketable the emperor
Constantine converted and by the Middle
Ages even Kings and Aristocrats were
kneeling down not to powerful Warrior
gods made in their own image but to a
god that was weak
suffering
victimized
oppressed so by the 19th century slave
morality had become the only morality
and it's not just Christianity either
the secular version of these values
became socialism anarchism about freeth
thinkers and atheists Nija has this to
say we loathe the church not its poison
apart from the church we too love the
poison okay the poison what is the PO
poison well Frederick thinks that
resentment poisons the mind and turns
humans against our own Natural Instincts
not just against aggression but against
sexuality against ambition against power
against life itself and there's two
possible outcomes of this one is that
resentment becomes a political movement
the conspiracy of those who suffer the
tyranny of the herd the revolution that
eats itself only we are good and just is
what they say as though Health success
strength pride and the feeling of power
were in themselves depravities for which
Penance bitter Penance will one day be
exacted among them we find plenty of
Vengeance Seekers disguised as judges
with the word justice Contin in their
mouth like poisonous spittle so you get
the mentality of a hyperm moralistic
resentment mob which I'm sure we're all
familiar with the other outcome is that
this moralism turns inward and attacks
the individual conscience producing
aestheticism
self-denial guilt because slave morality
condemns not only the external beasts of
prey who are oppressing us but also the
Beast of prey within our own animal
instincts what Christianity calls sin so
Frederick thinks that modern humans have
become sick we hate ourselves we hate
our own nature we hate life itself I
mean is he wrong you see a girl boss
winning
I only see the will to power Frederick
thinks of Modern Men as once proud wild
cats who've become domesticated house
pets at the cost of everything great in
the human Spirit that's very valid
fredric that's super hecking valid so
look I've been pretty positive about n
so far but I do have a couple critiques
I want to say one is that Frederick
associating slave morality with the Jews
is is very irresponsible even though he
didn't intend to be anti-semitic and
even though he was outspoken against
anti-Semitism in his own time when you
keep referring to the Christian values
you're critiquing as Jewish hatred and
Jewish Revenge some people might get the
wrong idea and some people did Frederick
like your dumbass sister Elizabeth n who
became a literal alternative ethno
identitarian God damn it Liz kind of
goth goals though yes that kind of goth
you're right this time my other critique
is that it doesn't seem to have occurred
to Frederick that genuinely caring about
other people is an option like not
because caring about other people is
repressing your true selfish nature but
just because caring about other people
is part of your nature and isn't it
isn't caring about other people also in
our nature I do think most of what n
says about resentment accurately
describes a very real thing but it's not
the only thing there is genuine care and
love in this world I've been told I
heard rumors and I'm even going to go so
far as to say # notall Christians Christ
I'm defending the Christians what is
this channel coming to there are
Christians maybe not most but still some
for whom love and forgiveness are
genuine experiences and not just some
kind of Twisted impotent passive
aggressive Vengeance where I agree with
n and with Freud is I do think a lot of
the emotional Foundation of justice and
morality is retribution
Envy or some combination of the two but
maybe it doesn't have to be that way
there's a famous Martin Luther King
quote responding to Nature what is
needed is a realization that power
without love is reckless and abusive and
that love without power is sentimental
anonym power at its best is love
implementing the demands of Justice and
Justice at its best is love correcting
everything that stands against
love so Reverend King concedes to n that
to Simply call power evil is a sickness
anemic but there still needs to be some
kind of emotional or spiritual force
that keeps Humanity from tearing itself
apart and maybe something like this
Christian idea of love for Humanity is
the missing peace because without
something like that I just see
retribution and envy snowballing into
human self-destruction and I hate that
for us it's not very sliving of us do
you guys know about sliving do you even
subscribe to Paris Hilton's YouTube
channel she doesn't have as many
subscribers as I do but you know I try
to support smaller creators living is
basically slaying and living your best
life into one word it's the new that's T
maybe I'll do a video about love when
I'm in a better mood so for now well
let's put it this way God is dead and we
have killed him M it's living
[Music]
okay I'm moisturized I'm primed I've
proven my academic credentials now it's
time to do my makeup that's right
children I'm going full baileyan I'm
going full suspish so I guess I should
say something about the political
implications of all this since uh I
guess this channel is about politics
sometimes I have to read my own
Wikipedia article to remember what I'm
doing with my life so this morality of
resentment of impotence and permanently
frustrated Revenge judges that power is
evil I don't use Foundation I just use
concealer I know that's like not how
you're supposed to do makeup but I don't
need to be good at makeup okay I have a
million subscribers on YouTube I don't
need to be good there was a New York
Times article about young women's
attitudes toward political ambition and
one of the women who was interviewed
said as a white woman I know I have
unearned privilege so am I really the
best person to be in leadership uh yes
yes you are because we need leaders like
you who are capable of questioning the
legitimacy of their own authority
otherwise we're just going to be stuck
with another blonde Beast of prey and of
course it's good to be aware of your
privilege especially as a leader but
let's not be so self effacing that we a
face ourselves off the face of the Earth
this is the self sabotage of resentment
values if you think power is evil then
you've given up on the ambition to
acquire any power which virtually
guarantees your political irrelevance
since like MLK said you have to at least
have some power to implement the demands
of Justice remember what incel is called
taking the black pill this conviction
that the reason you don't have a
girlfriend is just that you're
genetically undesirable there's nothing
you can do to change it and I guess
women are just too shallow to be
attracted to all the amazing hatred and
spite that festers in your heart for a
lot of blackpilled incels it seems like
there's only one thing left in life that
they enjoy which is simply the pleasure
of complaining of Moaning in pain it
reminds me of a comment from
dov's second most horrible protagonist
even in toothache there is enjoyment in
that case of course people are not
spiteful in silence but moan but they
are not candid moans they are malignant
moans and the malignancy is the whole
point the moan is a protest against the
meaninglessness of pain and part of the
satisfaction of Moaning is inflicting
your pain on other people this kind of
malignant moaning it's kind of the
opposite of music because a lot of music
like Blues is benevolent moaning that
transforms pain into pleasure I mean
that's what Blues is all about my woman
don't love me no more but I know her
sister will you know optimism I think a
lot of incel discourse is really just
malignant moaning right it's not an
attempt to diagnose or solve any problem
it's just a contagious expression of
misery a moan of pain that masquerades
as a political agenda sexual Marxism
they call it the redistribution of sex
State mandated GFS that's very valid of
course they don't actually expect any of
this to happen that's not the point so
incels are kind of a universal punching
bag online it's very easy to point and
laugh at them but what's harder is to
look in the mirror
and notice how these exact same
Tendencies are rampant in our own
communities so the inso of black pill is
just one instance of what I call an
ideology of resentment a discourse that
outwardly appears like moral or
political critique but which on
examination is mainly just a resentful
moan the goal of resentment politics is
not to improve conditions in fact the
resentful person is full of contempt for
any morally compromised sellouts who are
attempting to en act plausible reforms
they don't want Victory they don't want
Power they want to endlessly critique
power because for them critique is an
important psychological defense against
feeling impotent shayer described it
this way it is peculiar to ramont
criticism that it does not seriously
desire that its demands be fulfilled it
does not want to cure the evil the evil
is merely a pretext for the criticism
what am I going to do with my eyes I
think a pink kind of look even a lot of
pink looks I just I love that hay fever
look as a general rule the more radical
a political Community claims to be the
more likely it is to be a community of
resentment self- styled radicals will
tell you superficial surface reforms do
not interest us the problem must be
critiqued at its root and then the root
turns out to be this Universal
all-encompassing evil right Society
itself the system the machine a
resentment ideologue always imagines
himself self to be engaged in a kind of
satanic revolt against an omnipotent
omnipresent enemy okay I just need to do
makeup for a second it's harder than it
looks to be a makeup vlogger like it's
hard to talk while doing this and
nothing short of total Revolution counts
as any sort of Victory whatsoever we
have to dismantle the entire system burn
it all down I guess it's pedestrian to
point out that this is the Revolutionary
utopian equivalent of Christians
awaiting the last judgment our kingdom
is coming comrades often the appeal of
utopian ideology is similar to religion
it's not about health care higher wages
relief from police violence those are
actual goals that could be demanded
worked for and achieved utopian ideology
instead promises relief from some
general
malaise alienation and so ironically it
can have the same opiate effect that
Marx ascribed to religion but released
from the general anguish of human
existence is not a political goal
there's been many Revolutions in the
last few centuries and so far zero
Utopias resentment envy and hunger for
that matter are not satiated by the
downfall of the old regime when the
people have no bread they eat the
rich and when the rich are gone they eat
each other and because of the proximity
effect Envy may actually increase after
the revolution you may actually be more
envious of a favored comrade a
successful siton we a kulok than you
ever were of the aristocrats so eny
turns paranoid and imaginative in
Revolutionary moments it gets sublimated
into morality and the accusations start
flying that citizen is conspiring
against the revolution that peasant is
hoarding grain so the guillotine starts
slicing thousands of heads off the ggs
fill up or an authoritarian strong man
takes over just to announce another
Revolution two decades later the things
people will do to stay relevant honestly
and for what what long-term egalitarian
Utopia results socialism with Chinese
characteristics so look I do understand
that sometimes you just have to do a
revolution and if I'd been there in
1789 I'm sure I'd be storming the best
deal myself but I just wish we could
stop being so dyed about it Revolution
is a bloody nightmare that happens
because Society is collapsing and people
are desperate at worst Revolution is
nothing more than a violent day of
Retribution and at best it lays the
groundwork for future incremental
progress but it will never Usher in
Utopia nor is it the antidote to a vague
sense of unease which I'm sorry to
report is simply the resting state of an
unsedated human mind now I'm not saying
as some conservatives do that all
leftist or all egalitarian politics is
born of Envy no this is a specific
subtype there are PL plenty of reasons
other than Envy or fear of Envy to
oppose an economic distribution where
some people have billions of dollars
while other people are dying because
they can't afford insulin objectively
that is not an efficient use of
resources to promote human well-being
and personally I just don't want to live
in a country where people are dying
because they can't afford medicine and
I'm willing to pay however many taxes it
takes for that not to happen so while
I'm putting down straw man versions of
my argument I'm also not saying oh let's
just stop being envious no that's
impossible I think Envy is like libido
it's a basic force of human nature
that's more or less Unstoppable but with
the right leadership I think that Envy
can potentially be sublimated or
redirected into something more
constructive because raw Envy is a very
bad basis for egalitarian politics it
often targets the wrong people like
millionaires instead of billionaires and
eventually it turns the revolution
against itself and you get the circular
firing squad the self- cannibalism the
problem I see on the left today is that
without any genuine political Outlet
resentment mostly manifests as morality
morality itself being a way to vent
envious aggression and vindictiveness on
the left we claim to be so impersonal
right we're all about structural
analysis the material conditions systems
of power intersectional identity
hierarchies but if you look at what
people actually spend their time doing
here it's all this obsessive moral
policing I wonder if because leftists
can't seem to win on any major political
stage we feel disempowered and so this
moral fanaticism is a psychological
substitute like with Marie Antoinette
it's easier to blame people than systems
also structural analysis is very boring
and destroying people with gossip is
extremely entertaining this obsessive
moral policing also gets turned Inward
and becomes leftist guilt you know this
useless internalized scolding I think
I'm done with my makeup what do we think
leave a comment I'm always hesitant to
do anything about skin care since last
time I did skincare I was critiqued by
Hyrum so I am going to spray my face a
couple times with this this tatcha skin
Mist if that's okay with Hyrum it feels
good to finally address this Feud clear
the
air I look a lot better with makeup I
don't want to say that I don't have
natural beauty it's just that it's very
much enhanced by painting a a different
face on top of my face but hey at least
this way I've kind of like I've kind of
earned it you know because it's my skill
so there's a podcast called guilty
feminist that's been running for years
and I haven't listened in a while but in
the early episodes they'd bring on these
women who would confess their feminist
sins you know hi my name is Amber I'm a
feminist but I enjoy being choked in bed
it's hard being a woman not only are you
being choked you also feel guilty about
it the same moral hand ringing happens
with body positivity when you make
loving your body into a moral imperative
not only are you still going to hate
your body but now you're also going to
feel guilty about hating your body
because it makes you a bad feminist so
there was one problem and now there's
two problems thanks morality that's very
helpful now I want to take a moment to
acknowledge that a lot of conservatives
have made some version of the argument
I'm making in this video for example
Jordan Peterson and Camille Paia have
argued that academic postmodernists are
motivated by resentment the argument is
that deconstructionist literary theory
is a kind of envious Vengeance against
the beauty and virtuosity of canonical
great art and yeah there's probably some
truth to that a lot of academics are
failed artists but I was even more M
than that I've noticed that workingclass
non-academic socialists do tend to be
more productive and more self-advancing
involved in unionizing or organizing
whereas it's usually people who went to
college I went to
college presumably because they had
middle class Ambitions at some point but
whose middle class Ambitions have failed
who become the great critiquers of
capital I mean I can tell you from
experience that when I was eating Chef
Boyard over my Master's Degree that's
when I was most likely to say things
like according to Antonio GR in the
logic of L stage capitalism the
culturally demonic neoliberal ideology
manufactures the consent of the Cil uh
so point taken but some conservatives
take this argument way too far and try
to argue that the entire left is nothing
but a coalition of resentment like
there's a video on YouTube of the
philosophy Professor Steven Hicks doing
a version of the postmodernism is
resentment argument and in the comments
section there's a bunch of people saying
this describes black lives matter antifa
and the Democrats does it though I mean
any political movement is going to have
people in it who suffer from resentment
poisoning but black lives matter at its
core is about the right not to be
murdered by police the slogan black
lives matter is an affirmation of the
value of black life so that seems like
something even n would approve of Huey
Newton the co-founder of the Black
Panther Party was inspired by n to
create the slogan all power to the
people when we coined the expression all
power to the people we had in mind
emphasizing the word power for we
recognize that the will to power is the
basic Drive of man but it is incorrect
to seek power over people we have been
subjugated to the dehumanizing power of
exploitation and racism for hundreds of
years and the black community has its
Will To Power also what we seek however
is not power over people but the power
of control of our own destiny that to me
is a role model for how to do identity
politics without centering resentment
it's instead an affirmation of
self-determination and self-respect like
n would say it's saying yes to yourself
whereas if you're your whole political
project is defined in the negative then
you're allowing yourself to be defined
by your enemies I find feminism is prone
to this where even and in fact
especially the most radical feminists
cannot seem to escape this resentful
consciousness of being The Second Sex
and defining themselves against men
earlier I mentioned Andrea dworin in a
positive way she's the most radical of
radical feminists and my first impulse
is actually to defend her because she's
very widely hated and most of the people
who hate her hate a caricature like in
that Steven Hicks video Hicks summarizes
dworkin as calling all heterosexual
males rapists literally in the preface
to her most famous book Doran says if
one's sexual experience has always and
without exception been based on
dominance how could one understand that
this book does not say that all men are
rapists or that all intercourse is rap
listen Hicks I get that you're a full
professor and I'm just a makeup vlogger
but my gu feeling on this one is before
criticizing a book maybe read the book
just a thought get it together Prof
you're being owned online by a makeup
vlogger I mean there's no shame in that
it happens to me all the time that being
said I do think that hicks is
coincidentally correct that dworin is a
theorist of resentment what dworin does
say in this book is arguably even more
Bleak than what is falsely attributed to
her the book is called intercourse she
wrote a book called intercourse imagine
writing a book called intercourse of
course I can actually easily imagine
that never mind so this is an argument
about the meaning of sex penetration to
be specific dworin argues that
penetration expresses domination
Invasion occupation possession contempt
degradation so it's against the Freudian
male castration anxiety interpretation
where it's you know fear of being
devoured by the women imagine being
afraid of that imagine being afraid of
that I'm going to get a look of facelift
someday and I'm going to look like
this I'm perfect I certainly don't agree
with everything she says but isn't Doran
closer to the truth here closer than
Freud anyway you know think about what
men typically say to women during the
ACT do they say help I'm being devoured
never heard that one have you no usually
it's more along the lines of uh you like
that don't you you little Etc and of
course you can eroticize being
subjugated and degraded and enjoy it and
I think dorin would argue that most
women do eroticize subjugation because
they're taught to but enjoying it she'd
have to say doesn't change the meaning
of what's happening so I think Doran
says some things that are very true and
some things that are off the [ __ ]
rails where she loses me is where she
starts getting blackpilled and this book
this is the feminist black pill it is
250 pages of of hopeless misery and rage
she says male dominant gender hierarchy
seems immune to reform this may be
because because intercourse itself is
immune to reform uh okay so women will
never be free until men stop putting the
p in the v We Can Dream Andrea we can
dream like most ideology of resentment
this book is totally dismissive of any
plausible reforms that might actually
improve the situation of women instead
preferring to wallow in the endless
violence filth and objection of it all I
also think it's symptomatic that dworin
identifies as a lesbian but in that
second wave political way quoting from
the forward to dworin it was a badge of
rebellion against the patriarchy in 30
plus years of knowing her I've never
heard of a single romance with a woman
not one this is not surprising to me
from the author of a 250 page book about
sex that not once pauses to even imagine
the possibility of intimacy Between
Women because it's not a lesbianism
that's about saying yes to women it's a
lesbianism that's about saying no to men
you know people think that lesbians are
the biggest m man haters but I don't
think that's true I think lesbians just
don't think about men that much the only
men I think about are are Fred n and uh
edus the king it's straight women who
are usually the real manh haters cuz
they're stuck with this and love is
closer to hatred than neutrality so what
does Andrea dworin actually want what
would she say yes to if she said yes to
anything Sometimes women have trouble
saying what they want cuz no one ever
told them they could romance that's what
Jon didan said is the real desire of the
women's movement Jon didan of course
being not like other girls dwen offers
occasional glimpses of a positive desire
despite all efforts to socialize women
to one intercourse women still want a
more diffuse and tender sensuality that
evolves the whole body in a polymorphous
tenderness that does sound nice I'm so
lonely I think it's a bit bold to speak
for all women though like there are
definitely women out there who uh they
don't make love Anastasia
they hard I'm really sleepy and this bed
right behind me it just looks so nice
get in here right now whatever I just go
to sleep and then wake up and then just
record the rest of the video when I wake
up I don't want to do it now I'll get
Pikachu that'll make this easier isn't
it better for me to have a friend
Pikachu is the most adorable Pokemon why
cuz he's the yellowest name one thing
more yellow than Pikachu you can't name
any you can't think of anything so if
diffuse and tender sensuality is what
you want then just say that is that what
you want
Pikachu better it is and dorin did get
married to a gay man so I guess she
found what she wanted
lucky envying Andrea dorin is that
really what we've sunk to around here
you know I've been noticing the poison
creeping into my mind lately I know this
isn't very original but I had a bad year
you know I fell in love with my best
friend like a gay idiot got my heart
comprehensively broken and then Co hit
and gave me a year of solid itude to
spiral deeper into a hell of my own
making you know I stopped saying yes to
life and I started saying yes to chasing
the dragon by which I mean playing Spyro
the Dragon one of the greatest
appropriate for all ages video games of
all time look at him go I'm taking the
hair clips out I catch myself having
bitter spinster thoughts it's because
I'm trans it's because I'm gay that's
why I'll die alone you that's the reason
I'm alone definitely not because I don't
leave the house see I am not immune to
incel tier brain poisoning and you
really can use political theorizing as
an excuse not to fix your life Society
did this to me a transphobic Society
made me hate myself well yeah that's
true but at a certain point you have to
take responsibility for your own mind
and decide to stop being an accomplice
in your own Annihilation since we keep
referencing Paradise is lost the mind is
its own place and in itself can make a
heaven of Hell a hell of Heaven yes
Squad so I asked myself what kind of
mind do I want to be do I want to obsess
over what I lack concede society's
Judgment of my inferiority become a
self-hating self-pitying envious
resentful little nothing or do I want to
get off the godamn floor stop chasing
the dragon and say yes to life the
answer of course is that I long to
return to the the sweet womb of my dark
mother but we're not going to do that
because there's plenty of time to numb
the pain after you die the sweet Embrace
of death is the darkest mother of all
also nothing is less attractive than an
envious resentful self-pitying person
it's beyond a personality flaw it's a
personality deformity that can ruin
whatever chance at happiness you have so
in the short time that you're alive you
have to discover that which is Noble in
yourself and say yes to it you know
don't say no to getting older say yes to
being a mil yes yes uh what I'm really
trying to say here is SpongeBob
SquarePants is the Uber mench SpongeBob
says yes to life and so should we yes to
ourselves yes to Art yes to sensuality
yes to the world yes yes ER we is this
really how we're ending the video I
guess okay bye
[Music]
oh so what if my fantasies make no sense
you want to talk about things that don't
make sense heterosexuality let's put
that under the microscope H you want me
to believe that a straight woman who
knows the difference between magenta and
move is going to date a straight man who
thinks it's gay to wash his underwear
and that's just going to work out fine
you think it's safe to raise a child in
that
environment I don't think so not on my
watch see I think straight men should
date each other they can sit on the
couch all day playing Xbox and then each
other and then straight women can pair
off decoupage some [ __ ] and eat each
other out isn't that better isn't that
more rational I wish I could wiggle
these C ear like like I wish I had
anatomical control over them hello yes
Dr spel
yes it's me again I have a suggestion
what do we even have here we've got um
tuna salmon some squid um mackerel
shrimp um some I think it's Yellow Tail
clam some rolls I never been as much it
into rules I'm a cat you know I like
fish you start adding too much avocado
and rice into things it's in a front to
my feline nature
[Music]
oh
doctor I think of if a breeze comes into
the window I could die